california in the time of the
coronavirus
a state hit so hard that bodies are
being moved to temporary storage
containers
newly confirmed cases are rising at a
dizzying rate
despite lockdown restrictions now health
experts are warning that a more
contagious variant
first discovered in the uk could fuel
another wrenching surge of cases and
deaths
it could and likely will get worse in
the next couple of weeks or at least
maintain this very
terribly high level of infections and
deaths that we're seeing
vaccinations are rolling out albeit too
slowly but the u.s is nowhere close to
reaching herd immunity
covington that's all they talk about the
fake news kovitkova cometh
president donald trump continually
played down the pandemic
politicized the wearing of masks and
blamed states for moving too slowly
now with his presidency in its final
days it's trump who's being blamed for
failing to act
and allow the virus to spread so fast in
may the us recorded 100 000
deaths by september that figure doubled
now it's doubled again with a new
administration promising to ramp up
vaccinations
to a level that has so far come nowhere
near close to what was promised
look our plan is as clear as it is bold
get more people vaccinated for free
create more places for them to get
vaccinated
mobilize more medical teams to get the
shots in people's arms
increase supply and get it out the door
as soon as possible
for many 2021 was a year that would
bring renewed hope
instead new cases threaten to [ __ ]
already overwhelmed hospitals
claim more lives and leave many
wondering when this nation
will turn the corner according to the
journal of the american medical
association covert 19 is now a leading
cause of death in the u.s
outpacing both cancer and heart disease
one leading epidemiologist says the us
will beat covid but only after it's been
through hell
with vaccines on the horizon the end may
be in sight
but for many it'll be too late andy
gallacher al jazeera
miami florida well let's bring in dennis
nash he's the executive director of the
city university of new york's institute
for
implementation science in population
health he joins us via skype
from new york dennis so 400 000 deaths
across the u.s it's the country
as you know with the most number of
infections and deaths how would you sum
up
where the outgoing administration has
failed in its handling of this pandemic
well you know from a population health
standpoint uh this death toll is
of course a direct result of our
country's inability to adequately
control community spread but
but then given that we also have high
levels of community spread unfortunately
in the us that that 400k
death toll specifically has a lot to do
with our inability to protect our
elderly population in nursing homes
long-term care facility and other
congregate settings as well as our
essential workers during
pandemics um i think in the u.s at least
these settings are just not equipped to
detect or squelch outbreaks uh during a
pandemic
especially when there's no vaccine for
the pathogen
so there's no credible plan to ensure
you know workplace safety
and the lack of any credible or
effective response by the trump
trump administration um including one
that protects these populations is a
huge part of why we have such a high
death rate in the u.s
today and it absolutely didn't have to
be this high yeah dennis and
president-elect joe biden says his
number one priority
is the pandemic what are the main
challenges facing the new biden
administration from a public health
point of view
well i think you know there's a lot that
we've seen has gone
wrong in the past administration um i
think one of the
you know they need to turn the tide on
this current pandemic and i fully expect
to see
you know considered science-informed
strategies for prevention and mitigation
of spread
and um in the community and in
workplaces in addition to the vaccine
plan the vaccine plan is very important
but as we've heard
um you know there's also ongoing
community spread that is going to be
even faster while the vaccine is rolling
out and so
you know supporting healthcare workers
to provide the best available treatment
to covet patients and effective
implementation strategies for rapid and
i hope equitable
roll out of all these available vaccines
that are coming down the pipeline
informative public health messaging
leadership by example
leveraging technology and um you know
not privileging economic interests over
the more fundamental priorities yeah and
we're hearing that health officials in
california are investigating a mutated
strain of covid19
which may be different to others found
around the world
is this likely to make the rate of
infection much worse do you think
it's certainly a theoretical and very
concerning possibility
and you know this is why i think you
know we need to really
prioritize both prevention and
mitigation of spread
and speed up the vaccine roll out as
soon as possible yes
all right dennis nash thanks very much
indeed for your thoughts thank you for
talking to al jazeera
thank you